Is it working?
There we go. That looks
like it's maybe trying to work.
Okay,
cool. Hopefully I'm audible. Uh, yeah, I
think the settings are
more or less figured out. Um, my
lighting is kind of terrible, so I I am
a little ghostly. I promise I spent like
45 minutes trying to mess with the green
screen. Uh, and this is the least
terrible I've gotten. so far. So, I'll
I'll definitely be getting some better
lighting.
Uh, let me let me see if I can fuss with
my audio because I know
it's probably quiet right now.
I'm working on the audio right now.
Oh, okay. Looks like I can decel bump
it. That should be good.
Okay. Is that a bit better?
Am I Am I audible enough?
In principle, that should have boosted
my audio. Still quiet.
Um,
yes, I will be playing standard MTGO
with the Azorious Collected Company
artifact deck.
A bit better. I I'll I'll boost the I
don't want to peak, but I can boost the
can boost the only a little bit better.
Um
boost the volume a little bit more.
Okay,
let's try plus seven dB. Hopefully it
doesn't peak. Hello. Okay, maybe that's
better.
Let's go 10. See if it destroys
everybody's ears. Okay, so that's plus
10 dB.
Hopefully that doesn't peak. Hopefully I
don't see anything excitable.
Oh yeah, that's uh that's
that's a trinket mage helping me
troubleshoot. I'll turn off the the
sound on uh my Discord notifications.
Okay.
Okay. I think that's probably as good as
the audio is going to get. I I think I
need to trouble tr troubleshoot my audio
setup in general. Um it's easier to
control when I am making videos, but I
think uh I probably need a new
interface.
See?
Get this over here.
Okay. So, I'm playing an Azorious
Artifacts deck.
uh it is
is based around the card battle or
united battlefront and the card simul
synthesizer. So, uh, the Battlefront
grabs you two
lower cost, uh,
uh, like three or less cost non-creature
permanence, uh, not lands. And then the
other one grabs, uh, the Simul
synthesizer. Whenever you play a three
or more cost artifact, it gives you a
construct equal uh, with size equal to
the number of artifacts you control. So,
I kind of crammed the deck full of three
mana removal artifacts. So, that's kind
of the goal. It's it's very much kind of
a snowbally
deck, uh, where I'm just trying to get
my Simul synthesizer out and just play a
ton of three cost artifacts, you know,
remove things and create creatures. A
lot of three drops in the deck. There
are some other versions of the deck that
I know run um
Yeah. So, so the the deck list is going
to be on my architect page.
Okay, that
think I want a two drop here. So, not a
keep.
Wow, that's that's worse. Okay. Uh,
I can also just turn down the NGV sound
effects if they're too loud. They
definitely might be too loud. This is
fine.
[Music]
Okay, really loud.
Yeah, let me
go to OBS and turn down the desktop
audio bit and we'll see if that helps.
Uh
[Music]
is that a little bit less horribly loud?
Uh, similar synthesizer is just a really
broken card in general. So, that's kind
of why I ended up going with that.
I could probably just mute Joe sounds.
Yeah. Uh
don't need Oh, play against roots. That
could be a problem.
Okay.
Yeah. So, roots,
honestly, the roots part of roots is
less concerning than like looping
haywire mites with Tasha's cauldron. Um,
like roots is a scary card, but in
principle, that's not the issue. We
can't really see your hand through the
placement of the face cam. Oh. Uh,
yeah. Let's see.
Hold on.
I fuss around with my lighting a little
bit. Such a jank setup. I need any
better actual lighting.
Uh, that look a little bit less
horrible. Kind of.
Oh, overlord. Okay.
That actually that obscures the um let's
see.
Uh
if I could just like crop. No, that's
not how that works.
Um,
just stick myself in the corner here and
we'll we'll troubleshoot after the game
here. I'll scooch myself over so I'm a
little bit on camera.
Ah, that's the move. I see it. Yeah,
mirror it.
Let me see.
I'm going to probably do that during
sideboarding just so I need to stay a
little locked in for this.
Okay. ideally. That's not a good hit.
Uh, okay, that's fine.
Roots is really good, but it loses a
bunch of stuff at rotation. So, not a
bunch of stuff. I It doesn't lose roots,
but it loses like Taiibar at least. I
know. I'm grateful that it loses uh
haywire might because that is a very
gross card from a deck. In fact, that's
probably what I'm going to be seeing
very soon here.
Yep. Hello there. I don't have any good
artifacts out yet, so it's
Yeah,
makes sense.
You have artifacts get a bunch of
support. This deck could be like an
actual legit scary deck because nothing
in it really rotates. Um, like there's a
little bit of stuff in Brothers War that
I know some other people play, but
uh like most of the stuff is much more
recent.
Um,
that's So, I don't think he has the mana
to reanimate the
thing yet. So, I'm just going to hope
that I can deal with the tie bar before
too long.
No, I think I have to let Root stay
around for a turn.
Oh, I failed the tapping man a little.
Okay.
Another
similar to synthesizer wouldn't be bad
next turn. I can play that plus a
removal spell. That ends up being pretty
okay, I think.
Uh, MTG or Arena are both solid for um
for standard. Um,
yeah, I know it's it's it's definitely
become more of like a a digital format I
feel like. Um, but yeah, MGO you can
like rent decks which is nice. I have
not done that personally, but I know um
I have a friend who who does a lot of
that and works out pretty well for him.
See
mirror camera.
Yeah, this is not going to go well. I
don't think
I can avoid dealing with another
haywire, I might be okay. But it's a
little tricky.
Oh, yeah. Yeah. I know that's not good.
Okay,
I'm getting thoroughly rooted here.
I definitely need to be running
maidboard copies of uh
temporary lockdown because I'm not right
now and that seems like a very poor
decision.
I Yeah, I'm kind of far away from the
mic right now. I can
fuss with my
I just figure out how to
Yeah, I'm getting I'm getting so
thoroughly rooted. I think this game is
going to be over pretty pretty fast
here. Um,
this is very much a snowball deck unless
I have like a temporary lock down. So,
when I'm this far behind, it's kind of
unlikely that things will turn around.
Yeah, I actually know I have a simul on
top of my library. So, I think probably
I'm just going to scoop here and
fix my camera while sideboarding.
Okay. So
transform
uh flip horizontal. Okay. So we do that.
See,
that almost looks okay.
Okay, let's see.
Okay, sideboarding
the lockdowns. I have no idea how good
Rest in Peace is against
um
I have no idea how good Rest in Peace is
against Roots because it's not good
against the card roots itself, but it's
good in theory against everything else
the deck has. Um I'm going to try him
this game.
Uh I don't think
the higher cost of removal is just not
going to be efficient enough. So, I'm
going to yank out a couple.
It's not really an aggro deck. I'm going
to cut the carrot cakes as well. Try
that.
Okay, that's that's pretty decent.
If I can turn three simulator turn four
battlefront things go really well. So if
I can draw into a similar that should be
good. Although honestly this match up
depends so much on the haywire might
which is a little bit awkward.
Do not want more tap lands.
Wow. Okay.
Oh, did I just get my second turn?
Oh, lord.
So, this is cooked.
This is This is game two. Um I have a I
have a really bad match up against uh
Roots, so I
did not expect this to go particularly
well.
Intriguing. Okay,
if I can bait out the haywire might and
then rest in peace, that could
theoretically be a move for uh for
dealing with this.
Wow. Okay, that's not good.
Um
yeah,
let's think. Uh,
how foraging is forge? Exile three cards
from your graveyard.
Um,
so I really need to bait out both
haywire mites more or less here.
Yeah. What I'm going to do against that,
man. He has
two roots out. That's not good.
Um
Exile. Okay, it's exile instead. So
that's that's
in theory good.
Just going to pray to the Battlefront
gods.
See what happens here.
Okay, that's
I assume he
assume this person haywire mates in
response.
Uh
yeah, we'll see what happens there.
Yeah.
Dark Confidant.
All right. Yeah, I guess they refridded
that in uh in Final Fantasy. That's
interesting.
Not necessarily a card I would expect.
Okay.
Is there a move here? I don't think I
have enough white sources to do what I
need to do this turn. I should have
played my waste earlier.
Um
I gota do I guess that's awkward because
I'm going to do if I do one it might
honestly I may as well just
How many things are in graveyard right
now? Not a lot. I may as well just exile
the things that aren't might because I
know that if I exile might it's just
going to be a waste.
This person is hellbent. So if I can
just deny them value, I might be able to
manage this.
I think it's fine if that's up.
Okay. Yeah, that's still not that good
for them. They're they're low on
resources here.
whenever one or more creature cards.
So, in theory, if I rest in peace now, I
think that puts me in an okay spot is
um
yeah, I'm just going to try and bait out
the haywire might here.
It'll be one roots trigger, but that's
not that bad.
I keep the biggest creature tapped down
and
see if I can impulse for something.
I will take that.
I assume they just drew a land. I didn't
even see what they played.
Going to preemptively do that. So if I
get some removal, I can just
avoid having them nuke the removal in
response.
I definely kind of like the the kind of
circular
thing on the the promo insidious roots.
That's good. There we go. There we go.
Um, yeah, that's fine. I think that I
think that'll be perfectly solid this
game.
Probably only one of those.
Do paralous
net on top.
Oh, I'm I was just testing streaming in
general. Uh I could probably take test
out of there.
Uh,
I'm kind of surprised I won that.
Yeah, I'm not testing for any sort of uh
fancy stuff. This is just my
janky standard deck I'm playing around
with.
Although it's not it's not the fakest
like jankiest standard deck to ever
exist.
It is kind of a deck. Yeah, that's
that's really good actually.
probably take off that upkeep. Stop.
It's It's two lands, but I have I have
some filtering. So, and this deck has a
very high density of lands slash things
that can grab lands. What the heck is
this creature?
Huh, that's entirely useless against me
in this instance. So good.
Literally my only
main board instant I think is
um United Battlefront, which I mean it's
good if you can nail that, but I think
it's kind of unlikely.
Uh I so I don't play a ton of standard
so I
I mean I know when I played it a little
bit earlier this year no lands. Uh
that's a little awkward. When I played
it earlier this year it was definitely a
lot of mono red. Um I didn't even play
during the iset prowess
era. So but I the bands seem very good.
I think um
this town ain't big enough is the one
that seems maybe a little bit weird to
me, but even then like I I definitely
get it.
I mean
Gastra Vader grabs instant sorceries so
and I had none of that
thankfully.
Land, please.
Okay. Okay.
Uh, that's that's a little awkward.
That's fine. That's fine. We're good.
We're viving. I can pay for my land
drops like a commander player.
Yeah, this guy big enough. like I I
definitely
get it. It's it's it's definitely very
good with with some things. Um the only
reason it struck me as a little bit
weird was that uh it felt like the major
payoffs for it got removed or the major
enablers for it, I guess. Like the the
the black enchantment that makes people
discard that one was easily like the the
strongest with it thing with it. Um I
guess you could do something like just
blue, maybe red. uh do something with
mainly like the the one mana blue
enchantment in it that's still pretty
good. But um I don't really know. I
don't know if there's like a non black
non-green version of that deck that
would be strong. But it's it's
definitely possible. And I don't I don't
know what they're printing in the near
future.
Self bounce decks. definely might become
oppressive. I could I could totally see
that. Um
it's just all about finding the right
kind of uh strong lowc cost ETBs for the
deck. Okay.
Yeah, I do not think this is going to be
a win.
If I can get a land here, that sort of
helps. But yeah, missing my turn two
land drop was really bad.
Can I get a white land so I can at least
lock down? Okay. Uh,
what's the problem here?
Roots in the graveyard.
It's not a whole lot of graveyard
recursion.
Creature card two minute value two or
less. There's nothing.
Austin could get a little bit gross
there.
Um,
this could shut off planes walker
abilities, right? That's kind of neat.
Okay.
I'm going to try that.
Uh, the reason I'm morphing with the
background is because
my lighting is
not I mean my lighting works fine for
like just random facecam videos, but uh
it does not work well for green screens.
I think you need a lot more brightness
for for having your lighting work with a
green screen. So,
it's Yeah, I'll probably need to invest
in that.
I am getting a better camera soon. Um,
although I keep I keep buying better
cameras and then having them crap out on
me. So, I'm hoping that trend will stop.
See, I should have been doing this
during the the Dusk Mour standard so
that I had excuse I'm, you know, doing
my ghost cosplay.
Okay, it's a lot of stuff.
It's not
It's not a devastating amount of damage
yet.
Give me white land. I want to lock down.
Please.
Okay, that's a maybe. That's a maybe.
The thing about lock down here is that
if they remove it, I get a bunch of
draw.
So, it's not terrible. Uh, okay. Yeah,
there we go. That's what we needed.
Yeah, that definitely helps. It's a 32.
Um, I'll need to keep Ty locked down,
though. That that offers way too much
comeback potential here. I just got to
hope that I am able to
I just gota hope they don't draw
anything. And I got to hope that
uh I'm able to remove the stuff I need
to remove.
Okay.
Oh god, that's right. Haste.
All right.
Not a lot in graveyard actually though,
so it's not could be worse.
Do I even have
How do I survive this?
We gamble is how we survive this. That's
That's what.
All right.
Uh, is another lockdown good here?
Another lockdown is the funny choice. I
think it's the correct choice, too.
And in this case, I think I'm going to
eat the
Eat the tie bar here.
The upkeep.
Roots definitely looks pretty scary in
general. I feel like this person is
playing
some awkward choices in it cuz they've
just been they've just been going
hellbent like both of the past two games
in situations where they really
shouldn't be losing. Okay. Overlord.
Yeah, that's pretty good. Uh hopefully
they whiff. Maybe
that's kind of a whiff.
Yeah, that's Yeah, that's fine.
The fact that they still paid the
impending cost for Balemark because they
were one mana short makes me really
happy. Um because if they actually
played I mean I guess I could remove it
if they actually played bail but five
turns is so long. Like I have all the
time in the world to build a reward
here. Although I've been missing a lot
of land drops, which is the awkward
part.
Hey, it's a land drop. Thank you, buddy.
Um, yeah, I'm just putting up similar
crumb and hoping that I can start to
be a gamer next turn.
I don't have braided net up though. Oh,
do I just lose?
Do I just throw? I I don't have any
counters left my braided net. Oh no. Uh
oh.
Yeah, I don't think it matters. I have I
have bungled it.
I feel like I get more ghostly as I go.
Maybe I need to go back and fuss with
settings more.
Wow, I do not have hair.
Yeah.
Let me see if I can fuss with settings a
little bit.
Is that a little better? Uh, that makes
me disappear less, but it makes my green
screen disappear a lot more.
Something in the middle there.
I think that's fine enough.
A little bit of the hair disparance, but
I think that's okay.
That's it. It would have been really fun
if they had done another time spiral and
done spacecraft because that is such
like a
random janky time spiral sort of thing
to do.
I feel like they did riggers in one
unset and that almost or in in time
spiral and then it got later printed in
unset. That almost feels like cheating
cuz like you can put anything in an
unset. Uh that's a really good handish.
Okay. Okay.
My matchup against Deir Tempo is usually
pretty good
as long as I don't like load up too hard
on the counter spells. Also, if they
have a lot of hand disruption and I
start out with the battlefronts, it's a
little rough, but
it should be fine. Uh, we don't need
that.
Bricking it up.
Yeah, honestly, if they just want to
play a bunch of tempo creatures, that is
literally fine for me.
Counter spells and hand disruption and
maybe like Kaido are going to be the
concerning things here.
Do I just eat the mastermind? I think I
eat the mastermind here. Not that it
matters, but I just don't want to waste
mana.
Also, if I can bait out a counter spell,
that would be amazing because I do not
care. Okay, that's fine.
[Music]
It's a lot of open mana. Why is there so
much open mana? I don't like that.
I'm playing a uh United Battlefront
Psalm Simulator artifacts deck, so it's
just like removal spam. Get a ton of
constructs.
Uh, I don't know if this guy's a counter
spell or not. That's a concern.
Can I afford to get a United Battlefront
counter spell? I don't know if I can.
They might just be flooded. I'm going to
I'm going to take the risk.
I got two of it.
Maybe.
Whoa, it resolved. Okay. Lovely.
Fantastic.
That's so good. Okay,
so they are just flooded. They They're
not holding up a counter spell.
Uh, nope.
Nope.
Yeah, this person seems to be intensely
flooding.
I didn't have a counter spell last turn,
so just going to go for it again.
Do I should go for three minute? No, I
won't draw.
Yeah, some some um some tempo players do
not run a lot of uh counter spells at
all. Um I know a lot a lot of times a
bunch will come in in the sideboard uh
if they're,
you know, good players, but
um yeah,
typically any less counter spell
oriented Demir deck I play against, I
have a pretty good shot against. This
person is just fully flooding though, I
think. So that's just
kind of a gimme. Oh, what do we got?
Oh yeah. Okay.
I was expecting some sort of spicy four
mana instant.
I'm going to preemptively board in three
spell pierces.
Uh maybe two. I seeing three counter
spell light.
Yeah, I I usually drop the carrot cake
against decks that aren't full aggro. Um
that deir tempo can put on a little bit
of pressure, but it's not like the the
other decks where I desperately need a
blocker. Also, a lot of times the early
creatures are flying, so it's not that
relevant anyway.
Standard might push up the price of
shock lens a little bit, but I feel like
standard is less played in paper than it
used to be. So, I don't even know that
it'll be that significant.
Okay.
Yeah,
sure. That looks fine enough.
I guess I only have white mana for No, I
I'll have planes. That'll be fine.
The fact that Flood Farm Burge makes
white primarily is so relevant for this
deck because there's a white plain
scrabber.
Oh, wow.
I might get the full curve out. Oh,
yeah, that's fine. I might get the full
curve out here. So, if I can turn three
Simulator to turn four Battlefront, it's
it's kind of over for any slower deck.
A little bit less shadow on my face.
Sorcery. Oh go speed. I got it.
You want to play out a three drop, don't
you? I know you do. You want to tap out.
You don't need to counter things.
I have an extra. I'll run it out.
If I can drag out some counter spells,
that'll be good here. I have such a high
threat density in my hand.
Yeah, it's fine.
Popper is fun. I might do that actually.
Yeah, true. Tidebinder is a thing, but
it just doesn't meaningfully counter
much that I have in this deck.
If I actually if it counters like the
ETB trigger on one of my removal things,
it's pretty gross. But um otherw like if
it counters the uh the synthesizer,
usually I can just like remove it and
then keep chugging.
Uh MGO has other limited options I want
to try out like they have they have a
bunch of cube and stuff um other
formats. So uh definitely a little bit
of an older looking UI, but I think
there there's a lot of functionality
there for for trying stuff out. So they
tapped three mana. I think I can
probably run out the battlefront here
unless they're running spell pierces.
We'll see. We're about to discover if
they're running. Or I could also just
play out a simul and hold up spell
pierce. That's the move. Yeah,
I don't think I want either of those.
cool decks at Magicon.
I
I'm sure there were some. I'd have to
think. I've played a bunch of games.
I did play against somebody who had
fully
proxied out uh Pokemon alters for every
single card in their deck. Uh and it was
a Vololo deck and that that was pretty
funny.
Uh that was in that was in a little
bracket 2 game.
Yeah. Now we can run out the uh the
Battlefront with impunity.
Yeah, this is definitely good.
Oh yeah, there we go.
That's gross.
Yeah. So, this is what the this deck
kind of dreams of doing is just
similar and then just like crap out
removal at them.
Um, honestly, I don't have anything else
relevant to play in hand, so I may as
well just spell pierce that.
Uh, yeah, but the link to it is going to
be on my architect page. Um,
so if you if you
go to honestly if you just Google Cria
Snail, the architect page will pop up
and it should be at the top because I've
been tinkering this deck a lot recently,
messing with the sideboard and stuff.
Um, there are several other versions of
this deck, but um, this one's definitely
This one doesn't run uh the the artifact
pod card at the moment. I might try that
out because it seems possibly better
because I I'm running like this kind of
stuff for filtering that can be grabbed
off of uh ouch this kind of stuff for
filtering that can be grabbed off of um
United Battlefront, but I know a lot of
people are are doing the
um
I don't remember transmogrib or whatever
the the card that can sacrifice an
artifact find one with
higher one higher mana value pay for
cost duress. Okay. Yeah, I mean I can
get removal but I don't think that
really matters.
Let's go. All right.
Oh, I'm gaming.
Yeah, this is gross.
This is definitely just a smoosh people
sort of deck. You just
Yeah. Okay.
That'll That'll do it.
Yeah, my match up against Deir is is
pretty good and I their list didn't seem
all that tuned. So,
um I I generally don't face I I don't
really worry about Demir unless it's
like a a real like ladder grinder high
effort piling it piloting it.
That camera setup is actually looking
okayish.
Okay.
Uh,
no two drop, but I think it's good
enough.
I have a I have a scry at least. I can
try and dig into something.
Oh, is this person? I think I played
against this person. I want to say they
were on like just Jess just sky convoke.
This hand is way too slow to deal with
that.
Oh, I need to get in. Okay, I got the
clay fire bricks at least.
This is the sort of deck that I need
like a full
four. I think I want another land. This
is the kind of deck I need a full four
temporary lockdowns against.
This is just so gross.
Clearful demolition. Oh wow. Oh no.
Okay.
Okay. Okay. At least they Okay, that
that could be worse. They didn't have
any other payoff for it and they're on
three cards already. So, that's not too
bad.
If they have the convoke dude in hand
though, then I might be in trouble here.
Okay. Not inspect.
Sure.
Okay. Yeah, it's fine. A lot of life
endstep. Oh, they do not have what they
need. Okay, that's really good for me.
Um,
I don't even know if I remove something
here. I'll probably braid a net
actually. That's that's good for
defense. Or wait, what am I doing? Uh
simmer.
Um actually if I tuck that under the
impulse then I can uh battlefront into
it.
Yeah, we'll do that.
All right, let's see.
They need they they need this to be a
really big turn.
I Okay, it's going to give a lot of
damage, but I'm going to be able to
remove that. They'll put me down to
seven, I think.
Um Okay.
It's a little bit scary, but I think I
should be able to come back from this.
Although, I guess I I need to hit a uh
I really need to hit a a nonline
permanent removal in the top seven.
Well, it's gambling time.
Okay. Um
gives me blockers. So this could be
worse.
Does the Does the enchantment give haste
as well? It probably does.
That's just that that is the pick
regardless.
Yeah, trampoline haste. That might be
bad.
Reax the flyer.
That's Yeah, that's good.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Bottom.
Top.
There's a there's a similar card that
destroys an artifact and gets three
goblins. I think just like basic goblins
from like uh
second Miridan block. I think that that
was definitely big and popper. Okay, so
do they have a chunky creature? Oh,
okay. I I do have blockers though. I I
have seven seven blockers,
so this could be okay.
Oh, they do. Do they get to
Oh, that's not okay. No, that's not
okay. Oh, boy.
Yeah. Now I'm going to be a turn too
slow for this.
Uh, yeah. Now I'm fully cooked here.
It's definitely lockdowns.
I don't I don't think smite does
anything. I don't know that I need more
life total stabilization. I think it's
just the lockdowns we need. Um,
individual removal is not that great.
So, I'm going to cut
couple aegises. I think
I could cut carrot cakes. I don't know
that I hate carrot cakes, though.
They're They're okay. I got one carrot
cake.
I don't think Spell Pierce does that
much in this matchup. Like the cards I'm
worried about are uh like it's good
against some things, but I'm more
worried about Mass Artifact Destruction.
I'm worried about my stuff getting
countered and then if there's any like
key spells, but there's just not that
much key here. like Boros. Uh
Jessica Kvoke just has a lot of things
that do decently if uh
that that are just creatures.
Um I think I'm going to cut two Aegis.
I'm going to keep in the two copies of
Carrot Cake and we'll see how that goes.
Being on the play really helps against
this deck though. So that's going to be
massive.
Uh yeah, that's a lock down. That's a
Battlefront. That is a lovely hand
against this deck.
Oh, yeah. I could see that. I think I've
Yeah, that's actually really good for uh
temporary lockdown because they'll be
like tapping down and powering up this
creature rather than putting on
pressure. So, it kind of just means I
can do whatever I want for about
whatever I want, meaning finding planes.
But it it it might not even it's
probably not even going to be correct to
play the lock down next turn. I'll
probably wait a bit and see if I can
nail them a lot harder.
Yes, they're
checking out the dudes.
Yeah, I'm de I'm debating if I should do
it this next turn if I should do it
later because Okay, so see the awkward
thing is I want to play Battlefront on
four and Battlefront is really good if
they're on the back foot when I cast it.
Um,
let me see. I'll I'll see if I get a
different three drop. I'll definitely
consider it
if I get like a
Okay. Yeah, for sure. If I get that,
then yes, I can put it off.
Do I want the braided net?
I think that's pretty good.
Let's go. Top of library. Oh, okay. I
screwed that up actually.
Um,
damn.
That's fine. Nobody did that in my uh
battlefront.
Resolute reinforcements.
Synthesizer is so good. It's such a
gross magic card. Okay, so they're
they're fully fully gaming at this
point. Um,
I still think it's probably correct to
play Battlefront. Um,
and then the turn after I can lock down.
Wow. Okay.
Um, this is this is just white blue.
I might experiment with a different
version of United Battlefront that is
different colors. Okay.
Do I lock down?
Oh, they they uh they destroyed my my
that. Okay, that makes sense.
Yeah, I don't think there's that much
pressure here, so I'm just going to go
for it.
That's actually a really good thing to
snare because it does absolutely nothing
when it comes back in.
Yeah, they just don't have that much
pressure. So, I I uh
it'll definitely hit them pretty hard
when I do it a little bit later.
Um I mean, I guess that'll be hitting me
a little bit hard, but you know, still
I'm still at 20 on turn four, which is
really good.
Yeah, taking a little bit little bitty
bit of damage.
Um, okay.
So, I could bricks and then lock down.
Is that the move?
I mean, this recruiter is just a 22.
Like, I kind of have to do that just in
case they have another pump spell. Like,
I just cannot afford to let tokens be on
board with a lot of mana available.
So, yeah, going to do that.
That's fair. Yeah, I could see it being
better for for repurposing Bay. Um I'm
I'm going currently bayless with this
deck, but uh it's it's a Repurposing Bay
is really good, so I should probably run
it.
All right. No pump.
Okay. Yeah, this is not this is not
really scary.
Just need to keep finding value and I
should be good here.
Tigers
braided.
Okay.
Yeah, I'll I'll wait one more turn on
the temporary lockdown and then that
should be a pretty nasty followup.
Oh, was it? How much damage is Oh, it's
copying. Oh, I assumed it was going to
be imidance for critter. That's
interesting.
Yeah, that's fine. Oh, they have another
imitance.
Uh
yeah, I mean there's nothing I can do
against the cast.
Is that lethal? Oh, it gives it self
haste, doesn't it? Yeah, it's 100%
lethal. Okay.
All right.
Yeah.
I'll go into one more leak here.
I also might stream some like vintage
cube or something. I know that's going
to be coming back into existence
uh in a couple days. So, I know that's
popular among a lot of people.
It's not a great opening hand.
The dragon storm's not bad though.
Gives me a little bit of filtering.
Okay.
Okay. I mean, my hand sucks right now,
so that's fine.
Take my braided net or whatever.
I have not tried MTGO for commander
games, so I I do I don't know whether it
would be better for that. Um, but
certainly as like a 1v one platform,
it's it's pretty good.
I know I was thinking of trying to set
up some kind of commander gameplay and
it's definitely always a question of,
you know, do I do spell table? Do I do
it's like spell table, MTGO, cockatrice,
tabletop simulator? Uh, yeah, any any
number of these.
Um,
I like cockatric personally, but
I don't know. I could definitely try
some of the others. I know a lot of
people like TTS. Um, I could I could
definitely live brew that. That could be
kind of fun. Um,
I know I have a handful of decks I'm I'm
cooking, so
that's that's definitely fun to get into
all my thoughts with that.
Excuse.
Pretty slow roll out from this deck. No
dorks or anything, which is interesting.
Um,
two meticulous archives.
Gross.
Yeah, spell table looks the nicest. Did
I mess up my mana? Oh, no, no, no.
That's right. I was going to cast Dragon
Storm.
Yeah, get out of here. Archive.
Yeah, spell table is probably the best
looking overall.
I was I was thinking of uh trying to to
get Hans in on on something or other. Um
we we'll see about that. I have I have
some some plans for the summer that that
could be cool. That's fine.
What is this? Is Is this Is this Roots
or is this something else? Cuz Scoot
makes me think Roots, but Roots runs a
ton of low drops.
I have not heard of TCG Arena. Is that
like some sort of a
like um TTSesque program or
cockatricesque program where it's just
like a kind of interface where you can
play in
this hand is not great currently.
This hand isn't good. My opponent isn't
doing anything good either. So it it
evens out.
Yeah. If I if I were to do MTGO, it
would not be streamed. It would be um it
would be edited and made into a video.
I don't even know if I I definitely
could stream EDH, but um
uh I'm definitely more more
long form editedrained.
We got Oh, yeah. Yeah. Getting gaining a
little bit of life.
X mage. Interesting. Okay,
I have not heard of that.
My hand still sucks.
Guess I can nail the other removal spell
in it.
Sure,
that's fine.
Okay, that's good. That's good.
Finding us some filtering.
This game is so cooked.
Neither of us are doing anything. This
is very funny.
No, not end. Go away.
Okay.
Yeah, Commander is interesting because
it's it's it's
more like a like complicated Euro game
than it is like 1v one Magic in terms of
what it requires. So, kind of makes
sense that there are specific platforms
that are better for it. Okay, that's a
Battlefront.
Uh, do I run it out now or do I remove?
I think there's a pretty good chance the
Battlefront will hit something gets me a
blocker anyway, so I'm just going to run
that out.
Woo! Let's go.
Let's try removal. I kind of want
removal.
I could also dig deeper for like some
draw or something like another
battlefront.
Uh I'm kind of inclined to do that
actually.
I have another set of scry. May as well
take make use of it.
That I'll keep around because I can
double removal next turn. That ends up
being pretty good, I think. Actually,
I probably can't rub next turn because I
won't have a land to play. But
in principle, it's okay.
Honestly, this game is so slow that I
can just flip the clay fire bricks and
have that be a source of value. Oh,
okay. Okay. For sure. For sure. For
sure. Getting
a little apocalyptic in here.
Oh,
wait. Hold on. Can I Can I do that? I
didn't know this was my draw step.
Oh, what are you doing to me?
No. All right, buddy.
Cool.
Uh, I guess I'll miss a land drop.
That's fine. Spider's going to lose
anyway.
Control
Z.
That didn't even occur to me. I don't
know why.
I'm glad you're here to to point out my
my streaming
my uh my MTG streaming issues.
I don't Was that just like green black
mid-range or something?
You control Z and control Y.
Um, let's think.
Uh, I think I might just go for
I don't really have anything to
sideboard in other than more removal.
So, I'm just going to do that.
Uh, I could throw in an iron Craig to
get more to get my fast roll outs more
often. That could be kind of fun. Uh, I
guess there some mass artifact
destruction so I can pop in a spell
pierce. I'll do that.
Uh, that's fine. I think yes, Hans is
real. As it turns out,
he's he's not a plot by me to have my
YouTube videos be more interesting.
Do I want a braided net? I don't know
that I want a braided net.
I don't think it really matters. I'm
going to put in my graveyard and see if
I can find more like a simul
synthesizer.
Yeah, I still don't really have any good
artifacts in hand. That is totally fine.
Much better than a dess would be.
True. I I could be popping in here with
an alt account to to tell myself how to
not
not waste mana.
that that that would be that that would
be a gamer move.
Clearly, I'll have to come up with some
more decisive evidence for for you all.
It is seeming more and more like a
conspiracy the more I think about it.
True. My my my friends Hans cooked up
this deck. You see, you know, this this
deranged nonsense deck. I would never
make something like that. I'm a fine and
proper Magic player, but yeah, he he he
really loves to cook up that sort of
garbage.
Yeah, this is this this this game is not
going to go well for this person.
library.
Got to have a dark snail presenter to
keep things spicy.
So,
what does this person actually do? Do
they have like If they have mass
artifacts destruction, that'll help them
a little bit. Although, I think I could
I I could play through at least one of
those. I think Terracender. Sure.
It's fair enough.
See if I can find something off an
impulse.
What do we got? That's what we got.
Hell yeah.
braided net. Braided net. Uh, honestly,
flipping a braided net here wouldn't be
bad because I'm a little bit low on
cards.
I think I should put them both on top.
Well, I can only play one next turn. Put
one on bottom, one on top.
Okay. It's It's funny you suggest a low
to the ground ratta deck because for a
while my like MTG arena brawl deck that
I would play uh was
Galissa aggro uh three mana Glysa aggro.
because I had my I had my Glypha battle
cruiser deck, but as it turns out, if
you're one v oneing somebody, it's a lot
better to just run Glysa as a sick
beater and draw engine and then
treat it kind of like a Delver deck
where you're running a ton of
interaction to to slow people down as
you swing in at them.
Delver deck or a Jun deck? I don't I
don't know what you'd quantify it as.
Yeah, that's
that can that can destroy my
synthesizer. Okay, I don't care about
the other modes.
See, but Edgar Marov with 20 lands,
maybe not with 20 lands, but
Edgar Marov with super super low curved
everything sounds kind of fun, not going
to lie.
Like it's an expensive commander and I
don't want to be that guy, but like it
sounds kind of fun.
Nothing but one drop nonsense.
Vampires.
Okay.
Um,
I'm just going to see if I can draw into
something else.
This person has managed to keep my
artifact count relatively low, which is
awkward for vault and net because th
those very much care about specifically
your artifact.
Ditch the wastes there.
Um,
get clay fire bricks after that.
Do I push in? They're on three cards.
Yeah, sure. I'll push in.
I have answers if they start going aggro
on me. This seems like a pretty slow
deck in general.
At least slow by the standards of
current standard.
I consider Deir mid-range to be like a a
very middle of the road speed deck. And
that still was like kind of a like fast
slightly aggroy deck, but it's just not
that fast in the scope of like mono red.
Even even post bands uh aggro decks are
pretty gross fast.
That's an interesting inclusion. I can
see it being a sideboard.
What artifact? Oh, destroys the
construct.
Okay, sure.
Fair enough. Live your best life.
Plus one is card advantage. Yeah,
we'll see if I can lock out that
planaines walker.
Um, do I have enough mana to vault?
Yeah, I do have enough mana to fall in
there.
I can take a couple hits from that 33.
With my dragon deck, I actually play
with the uh draw the top 20, keep seven
policy for for mulligans, but you also
get one free mulligan, of course,
because you got you got to make sure you
get a good hand to start the game with.
Okay, that's a shield for sure.
Oh, did I
miss this activation? Yes, this is post
bands. Bands are instantaneous.
Uh, apparently I should activate for my
vault on my turn or else I'll just
accidentally tab through it.
All right. Actually, no. Hold on. Should
eat a shield first. Oh. Oh my god, not
again. Okay, control Z. Control Z
control Z.
I don't have responses to children.
Uh, okay.
I'll have to eat a bit of damage from
the tranquil draw back, which is not
super ideal, but
oh well.
Tasty.
I play the flood farm verge.
Um, oh wait, seven mana is a lot.
As long as I have enough mana to
potentially for vault plus
Battlefront, then it's decent.
This person Yeah, this person could
potentially attrition me if I don't find
a battlefront soon, which is a little
bit awkward. Um,
if I find another answer for Vivian
Reed, I can at least start to spend the
mana to
flip braided net, which is decent, but
uh, that takes a lot of mana, too. So,
it's a little bit awkward.
All right, what do we got?
Okay, for sure.
Obliterator.
Um,
I think I just uh similar chrome plus
that and that's pretty good place.
What do we got?
Um, that's tasty enough.
Can do that plus for next turn.
Yes, this is going to go pretty well, I
think.
questions. Do I dig for a battlefront?
I think I can do better than uh
assimilation actually.
Yeah, cuz I have
that leaves me with three mana. So, if I
get rid of this, I can play a
Battlefront if I find it.
Yeah, there we go.
Oh, do I feel any pressure to play well
or pop off? Uh,
like a very minor pressure. Like if my
deck absolutely does nothing, that feels
kind of bad. Um,
but ultimately like that's also
variance. Like, uh, I know one of the
benefits of playing my my Rata deck is
just that it's so goddamn consistent
that it'll always end up looking pretty
good. Um, and at Magicon, my Rada deck
was so
gross.
Like, it's this like $80 no game changer
deck. I was playing in bracket three and
just mostly I think I won like five out
of the six games I played with it. Um,
so I I definitely have some decks that
will consistently pop off. Uh, but if
I'm playing something like my Sharon
slide deck, it'll it's so matchup
dependent. If people have too much
pressure, I will just be too slow.
I really don't get to see my hand before
my opponent chooses to go first.
Nope.
Uh that's Yeah, that's that's good.
I get rid of my Yeah, I get my fourth
land, I think.
I'm missing something.
What's happening?
Okay, there we go.
What's going on there?
Oh, is it another Demir match up? Okay.
Although that that's actually that is
potentially better against this specific
hand because I'm definitely shooting for
a a like fast uh Battlefront here. I
mean, that that definitely stays. plenty
good.
But we'll see if if they want to tap
out. I'm going to be a little giddy
going into turn three because if I can
turn three battlefront, a lot of times
that'll just be
over so fast.
They can also counter my iron crack if
they want. That would also be entirely
fine as long as I draw fourth land.
Okay,
I could also draw because I'm not
running spell pierce yet. That that'll
be boarded in
combat. They're holding up mana.
I'm just going to go ahead and
play it safe. Guarantee fourth land
drop.
Yeah, let's do that.
I only got one mana open. You better
counter it.
Um,
bricks is good. I don't think I need
that many of the
uh
That is a pretty spicy statement there,
Lord of Ravens. But, uh, I'll I'll I'll
try to avoid taking too much offense at
it.
Come on, buddy. You You know you want to
tap out. They don't want to tap out.
Okay.
Well, I can at least play
uh synthesizer here and get around the
counter unless they pay two and then if
that doesn't pan out. Okay, great.
Lovely. Uh
do I want those?
I don't think I want more lands. Period.
And I don't know if I'm playing
Battlefront next turn or not. So,
I'm just going to put the both on bottom
to keep my impulse fully powered for
finding something
just like powering up their soul stone.
Yeah.
Is this a blue black drago or is this a
very cautious mid-range player?
I've considered stacks effects in that
deck, but it's never felt all that
necessary because the deck is so much
about um
resource denial in general, like but but
different forms of resource denial. like
I try to cut off people's uh ability to
gain resources by killing value engines
and stuff rather than, you know,
uh trying letting them have the cards or
letting them have the mana but then uh
trying to prevent them from using it.
So, I definitely could add it. Um if
there if there was one printed that I
guess there's like uh the one that's
like each player can only cast more than
one non artifact spell per turn. So, in
principle, that's solid. But I don't
know. I I don't really find the need.
I might if I'm trying to power up that
deck, though. All right. What do we got?
Show me your three steps ahead.
Three steps ahead.
Are you three steps ahead? Spelling
exhale. Oh, they holding a dragon. I
guess they must be.
Oh, no. Is that Oh,
okay.
Yeah, I guess that's how that works for
sure.
All right.
[Music]
Yeah. So definitely like a that is
definitely dealing with some sort of
blue black drago control.
All right.
Brute force the control player with a
stream of Battlefronts.
Interesting.
I'm not running that many creatures. You
know, I imagine that's their anti-agro
card, so not going to disagree with it.
Do I just try and eat this?
I imagine that would also get countered.
So, I don't know if it actually matters.
Actually, I can pop the carrot cake for
another blocker. So, I'm not going to
worry about it.
All right. Give me all your counter
spells. Oh, okay.
Um, didn't hit any value, but that's
fine, I think.
Oh [__] I picked the wrong one. Uh,
yeah, cuz it's non land permanent. God
damn it. All right,
that's fine.
Yes, that's going to be a whole lot of
nothing.
What do we got?
Tide binder. Okay.
for sure
that that only shuts off one of the
triggers. I still get the the construct
and I can just remove the tide binder
next turn. If I draw a land, I can
remove the tide binder and play another
battlefront which is pretty good.
Tap down this. Yeah, why not? Oh no,
it's non permit I guess.
Let's get more info on your posture.
All right, stop talking in the chat for
a bit. Uh,
I am doing pretty good. I I'm struggling
a little with a green screen. I'll have
to I'll have to find some better
lighting for that. But it's good. I've
been wanting to start trying streaming.
It's kind of fun. Um, I'd actually been
considering doing some sort of revamp on
the $25 budget decks, maybe even trying
to get a new pool together. Uh, but
that's that's very much in the works.
Uh, and I'm still trying to figure out
um how that would work with kind of busy
people and and all of that. So,
uh,
It's it's it's very much a cool deck
building experience to build with um
with that sort of budget just because
the the trade-offs are so intense. Like
you go, "Wow, a $120 that is way too
goddamn expensive for that card." Unless
it's absolutely amazing. Sacrifice a
token up. Sure.
U
land here.
Yeah, that's useless to me right now.
Give me a land. Come on.
Um,
that that's not too bad actually. Uh, I
actually have been planning on doing
some sort of gameplay content this
summer now that I have my second
channel. Uh, so I I'll probably figure
out at least some environment for the
three of us to play over Spell Table.
That seems kind of fun.
All
right,
I think that's all I got for now.
I need to play faster. I'm running
through my clock.
Still dro controlling.
Uh question is, do they have counter
spells? That's what I'm kind of curious
about.
Have fun with your commander game, D.
I'm glad you got to pop in.
Resolves. Okay, I'll take it.
I might figure out some sort of other
way to do deck building challenges. Um,
keep that on top. I I'll I'll try and
play Battlefront next turn. That should
be kind of good for that.
Um,
I want to figure out some way that is
less time consuming. I would probably
make it less timeconuming for myself and
put it on the second channel if I was
going to do deck building challenges in
the future for like my like the Discord
and stuff. Um, that just makes it a lot
easier on me if I can do that.
because ultimately like when I when I
turn it into a main channel video, it's
not too bad, but those videos also don't
generally perform all that well compared
to my other ones. So, um it's definitely
trade-offs.
What do we got?
Sure.
Are they paying the four? Okay, sure.
I'm glad you like the tool. I know me
and my brother are working on a big
update for it this summer. So that Okay,
that will offer a lot of We got the non-
ninjitsued Kaido. Okay, that's fine.
Yeah, can't even do the the plus one
plus one or the the surveil.
That's
Um, yeah, big big man base tool update
coming later this summer. So, that
that's going to be pretty exciting. I
think that should be definitely cool for
anybody who is looking for a lot more
features out of it. Um, and a lot more
ways to customize it. Um, I think the
initial version was definitely good for
the average user, but uh,
main phase.
I'm just going to go go for it here. I
think
hopefully I fully finished my thought
there.
That's pretty good. Oh, that that
actually is just lethal, I think. Oh,
no. Actually, one of those was tapped
down, so not No, that is lethal. Yeah.
Easy.
No, no, it's not.
Oh,
lethal enough.
Uh, spell pierces go in. I don't think
anything else goes in.
Cut like maybe
aegis
I guess.
Okay. Okay, so there was a lot of Demir
mid-range stuff played near the end
there, which is kind of funny because I
figured it I figured it was a full draw
go because I saw the weird dragon
counter spell and there was literally
nothing played early. Um,
but I I think these sideboard changes
are good for both Demir mid-range and
um any sort of slower deck. So if this
is like an off control riff on Deir,
that's that's fine as well.
Yeah, lovely hand.
Take off the upkeep thing until I play
my uh braided net. Oh, that's not good.
Okay, that's fine.
I got a little bit of filtering. All
right.
We don't love to see it. Unless that
happens, which case we're okay with
seeing it.
There might still be a bat though to to
cut the other one.
All right, we got the 2-1 vigilance.
Heck yeah.
Come on, buddy. You You know you want to
tap out and play a Kaido. You're you're
you're you're dying to tap out and play
a Kaido.
Come on. Give me the Kaido. Yeah. Here
we go.
This person thinks they're safe from
United Battlefront.
Do I double synthesizer here? It's blue
black, so I don't have any mass removal.
So I think I think I'm going to go
greedy and double synthesizer. Um, the
Kaido is not that concerning here.
Um, that's
honestly I'm kind of just keep them like
that because that would be very nice to
have next turn.
Doesn't matter what order they're in
because I I'm going to be playing my
roing dragon storm. I could also
actually no I could play uh clayfire
bricks as well.
I don't think it really matters one way
or the other.
bottom top. If I get like another
If I get like another battlefront, then
I'll keep it there. That's intriguing. I
don't think it matters where they are.
Top. Top. That's fine.
I'll definitely look into doing some
deck building streams because I've been
meaning to update some of my decks. Uh,
yeah, it just does so little here. I
guess it could save Kaido from an
attack. That's probably what this person
is shooting for. But that's if that's
your goal in a game where there's two
similar synthesizers against you, you're
you're not having fun.
My my chat is called the Slimers.
So that's that's where we're going to go
with. I'm I'm not I will not be
considering any other options here. That
seems like the perfect choice.
or the slimy folks. It's got to be
something slimy.
What's that countering? Is that
countering the the synthesizer or is it
countering? Okay, it's counting the
synthesizer. Sure.
How mildly annoying but ultimately
inconsequential. I guess I should have
swung there.
Slime bags.
That's pretty good.
Bill Fernie Bree Swindler monu horse
with some twists.
That's intriguing.
This person's fully cooked. Or maybe
there's I guess they're holding
interaction.
Interaction's going to like they can
prevent me from killing the tide binder.
theoretically, but I don't even think
it's that good.
Oh, well, don't be the salt shakers.
That's just rude. You can't be doing
that.
Uh,
actually, if I hold up the spell pierce
Oh, but I didn't draw land.
[Music]
Huh.
Hoping I would draw land here.
I mean, we we'll try it.
We'll get through the
interaction eventually.
Guess I could have swung first
theoretically.
Salt Shakers would be good if I was
going to, you know, develop an
antagonistic relationship with uh with
chat, but um just
just for me personally, I'm not really
looking to get uh get swatted, so I
probably will not
Uh, standard might be a real format. Who
knows? It It's a lot more real than it
was very recently where there was the
top that was for mono red for is proud.
Um,
yeah, I'll definitely be looking at uh
gameplay content for for later this
summer because I definitely I want to
get some of that going on my second
channel. Although I'll have to figure
out how long it takes to edit.
That'll definitely be the uh determining
factor of how much I can put up for
sure.
Oh, there we go. That's a little bit
less
less shade on my face.
I think they were definitely ambitious
with the the three-year extension, but
at least in this case, what they're
doing is
directly responding to player feedback.
So, you know, even if standard is in a
bit of a weird place, I think it's this
set of bannings is a good sign at least.
Um, now where things go from here, I
don't know, but
it's a good sign. And there are people
who care about standard for sure who
aren't, you know, wizards of the coast.
Uh,
it's not a great hand.
That is it's okay. Like if I can
I just don't want this much three mana
interaction in my opening hand.
I do have all colors of mana though.
I'll I'll try it out.
Fellow blue white player.
Okay. Blue I control. It's got to be
blueey control.
I don't think there are any other blue
white decks in the format that would
play um
that would play normalize.
Not saying it's a bad card. It's just I
I'm I'm
definitely not playing anything but but
spell pierce.
Although, if I start playing with a lot
of control, I might uh pop in offer as
well. That's decent.
I think I counter my clay fire bricks.
How much of a gamer is this person?
It's clayfired pricks.
Wow. Okay. Yeah. Go off.
I guess it's decent in this case because
I don't have a land in hand. So
maybe my tiny tiny stream is getting
sniped.
You never know.
Um, save up for impulse. Yeah,
probably impulsing for a land. Maybe
this is a really, really bad hand we're
playing this control deck control with,
though. It's a little bit rough.
I think this is blue I draw for sure.
I'm the only tempo player who would ever
run an impulse.
Okay, they're tapping out.
They're tapping out. They're tapping
out.
I guess maybe they they're fully tapping
out. Okay, I just need to find a land.
That's all I need to do.
I was not expecting this opportunity.
Okay, untapped land. That's all I want.
We'll take it.
Yeah, buddy.
All right. If I can hit a synthesizer
off of this, that would be really,
really nice. Um,
it's a weak hit. Gives me a little bit
of mana at least. It's not too bad.
Um,
it's fine.
The fact they counted the clay fire
bricks is wild. That's crazy.
I do also have the clay fire bricks in
my graveyard now to craft with on this.
I might just do that immediately.
Start chugging my way toward some
card draw.
Yeah, I'm just going to do that.
going to counter this.
Is that what you're saving your counters
for? The removal spell with no targets.
Done.
If somebody tied binded the the trigger
on that, that would be kind of
disgusting. But
yeah, I don't I don't think hard control
runs tide binder. They they might, but
it's worse than a lot of other options.
So that'll be three cards currently.
Yeah. Yeah. They're they're their dragon
control.
I can't imagine how counter heavy they
are if uh if if they wanted to counter
the the uh gravel planes card, but they
they might be popping off with counters.
All right, what do we got? Mainland.
Are they playing the mering? Oh. Oh,
that sucks. That sucks actually. Okay.
All right.
Doesn't suck that much. It just slows
down my my draw a bit. I'm surprised
they would bounce that rather than the
rock, though.
I guess it doesn't really It doesn't
really matter what the second target is.
They just want to slow down my card
draw.
I think. Yeah, it's just that.
Oh, actually
I should have No, that's that's only
small creatures. Yeah, that's fine.
This game is unfortunately going to be
terrible content because
h this is kind of just a miserable
stupid duck.
I mean, I was a control player back in
the day, so I can't judge too much, but
yeah,
I would look at the top three.
Could do that. That seems fine.
Yeah. Solid.
No.
It's It's It's really intense stuff.
gradually value crunching until I think
I can get around some counter spells
because ultimately I will just be trying
to
uh build up card advantage until I can
play things into counter spells without
worrying too much. Um
if I start seeing more of this I'm
definitely going to add some offer you
can't refuses because that actually lets
me play things mid game. But
we're tapping out. Oh, two charge
counters. I assume it's shooting for
three. Yeah, three would be pretty good
here. Although it wouldn't even be that
good.
Oh, wait. It's not my turn. Yeah, they
they'll get to do it immediately.
[Music]
Yeah, that's pretty good.
Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That's fine. It's
good to get it over with now.
I have kind of a mana advantage, so I'm
inclined to try and just start crunching
through the counter spells.
Come on, show me the counter spell. You
know you want to. You know you want to
counter this. You like your dragon. Come
on, buddy. Look at that ice dragon. And
I'm going to confiscate it. Oh, that's
good. Here we go. Yeah, that's the thing
you want to counter this turn. Yep.
Sick. That's good.
Not that. Not that. No, no, no, no, no.
Oh, okay. I can't control Z that. Okay.
That sucks. Sure.
That's That's why I need to click the
card first. That's my fault.
Okay.
Uh, my second channel is Salubrius with
the two in place of the U. I should
definitely link it to my primary channel
because I have not done that. Um, I
started it literally like five days ago
or something.
Oh, we're getting the bounce.
Yeah.
All right.
I just need to sideboard in for like
full rush next time. Just like spell
piercings. Honestly, this game I should
have won, but I just like totally
whiffed my first United Battlefront. I
can united Battlefront now though. I
have enough life total to survive that.
So, I I I still have a decent shot here.
Go like that.
Okay. Yeah.
So, we hit that. We hit that.
Although, I know there's going to be
like an ultimate coming up though, and
that's going to really suck. I don't
know how hard I should play into this.
Yeah, we'll keep that on top.
Um, I'm just going to play as if there's
going to be an ultima next turn. So, I'm
just going to play to rebuild.
So, we'll see if we can bait that out
right now. Get it over with.
Yeah, because if this doesn't bait an
Ultima, I don't know what will.
Ultima is the board wipe that destroys
all artifacts and creatures, which I I
expect to be happening in my very near
future. If it doesn't happen, then this
game is probably just a win, but I'm
pretty sure it's about to happen.
Show me the five mana.
Basa. That's not
That's not very Do they have a land play
left?
Okay, sure. That's awesome.
Um, yeah, super cool.
Okay,
true.
Bait another counter spell with the
bricks
there. This Yeah, may maybe. So, we'll
see.
Come on, buddy. Honestly, just the
smaller artifacts just get my artifact
count up so that these constructs punch
harder, which is decent in its own
right.
Okay, then with that that that allows me
to hold up a Famorei vault, which is
decent.
So, I'm not going to play out my second
simul. That would just be way too
greedy.
Did I [__] out my mana production?
Yeah, my my channel isn't that second
channel isn't big enough.
Did I shuffle? Oh, I did shuffle.
Okay, that's fine.
We'll discard that.
Giving them fish blocks.
Delicious fish blocks.
I don't have like a Yeah.
Okay. When is this person going to play
Ultima?
So that does let them get tokens here.
of all the board wipes. Why are you
running day of judgement? That's not
very good.
Okay. Oh, I should have a for agent
response. Oh well.
Tapping out for anth.
Okay.
It's a decent finisher, but like I don't
think this person's at the finishing
stage.
Thank you, Rocket. Rocket West Rock.
Uh, those go in.
Yeah. Um yeah, I already have a similar
in place. Yeah, I'll just battlefront
and see what we can do against this
person.
Yeah, we'll start there.
One one bolt.
I'm sorry. What?
Uh did I just whiff?
Oh, this program makes it way too hard
for me to be an idiot. Wow.
I hate everything. Okay,
I'm just making this control content so
much better with my fuckups.
Clefire bricks that pumps up my artifact
count. Give me something to discard to
Honestly,
I should throw in a massive anti-control
package to my sideboard just to just for
purposes of ending their life when they
make my streams boring.
That would be very satisfying.
In principle, this isn't a bad match up
for me. Um,
especially when I can board in some
counter spells.
But if I fully whiff my
Yes.
The gastro squad is pretty good.
Vald is so good against control.
It's just a really good card in general.
All right, another battlefront. We're
not going to whiff it this time. We're
going to have a lovely time
battlefronting.
Yeah, it's not that scary.
Yeah, I'm not using the for.
Oh, come on. You can give me another
three drop. Okay.
Yeah. All right. Got a synthesizer,
though.
once again. Playing as though there's an
ultimate coming. This does nothing if
they play an ultimate. So, I'm going to
bottom it.
I would keep a like nonline permanent
exile because I do need to kill
Elizabeth here. But
thank you, Oxymoron.
Pirate shanties are pretty good. I know.
I really like there's like a 10-minute
Decemberist song that's like a, you
know, tale of uh revenge on the sea.
That that's a lot of fun. It's not
technically pirate, but it's uh it's
good fun.
Okay,
what are we targeting with that? The
blockers.
This is a perplexing person.
They think they're in finishing mode.
Maybe they're in finishing mode.
Okay, how much mana do I actually have
this turn?
Vault plus four. Four of my mana.
Outside of that, I have one, two, three,
four, five, six.
[Music]
Not not a great number.
Is there anything else I can do with my
mana? I can make a blocker, I guess.
It's decent.
I mean, I play the simulator.
I guess counter cry though.
This is the counter spellless control
player.
I don't know if that actually helps me
here.
Actually, hold on. Do I have Do I have
the man to grab that? Yeah, I do have
the man to grab that. Okay. Um, let's
throw that on the bottom just in case I
see something else. But then that's fine
on top.
Yeah. And then we will
I wanted an exile off for the Elath, but
is it too greedy to grab a fourth?
Honestly, I'm just going all in. If I
get ultimate, I get ultimate.
I don't even know what I'm looking for
at this point.
Thank God. Do I die? Hell yeah.
Oh, I am so ready for this match to be
done.
At least I get to sideboard and attempt
something.
Sideboard in those.
Um,
board out the carrot cakes. Board out a
piece of creature removal. And that's
the deck.
I am pretty good this evening, Pidge.
Although it's afternoon where I am. Uh
although I am
I am playing against a control deck
right now which
yeah first game was rough. I I screwed
up a bit and got a little bit unlucky in
other bits and it was just all around a
lovely
20 minute game.
25 minute game.
I have 10 minutes left on my clock.
Thank god the suffering will end. Uh we
do not keep that. I want to end this
person. Okay. Yes, that is a more
aggressive hand.
Uh, ditch the second archive for sure.
Give me Give me a ramp rock. Come on.
Um,
nah,
I got impulse for filtering already.
Second Battlefront. Okay,
it's kind of cool. Kind of funky fresh.
All right. Are they going to counter my
impulse?
So, last game they countered my
they countered my bricks but then didn't
counter all of Okay, actually that's
iron crag is good here because that lets
me
that lets me uh ramp up to a spell
pierce protected battlefront
if I can find a
if I find a land it's a spell pierce
protected battlefront. I don't find a
lance pulp protected similar
synthesizer. I think it's fine all
around.
Yeah, I do pierce that.
If I had a bunch of extra lands, I might
not pierce that. But no, that's got to
get pierced.
Um,
I'm I'm just going to assume whatever I
play gets countered. What do I want to
bait with first?
I want to bait with the synthesizer.
Give me your counter spell. It's mine.
I'm confiscating it from your hand.
Success confiscated.
All right. Now, now tap out. That's
that. You know, you want to tap out.
Stock up. Yeah, let's play your stock up
B. Even better. Lovely. Get out that for
drop. You know you want it.
Okay, there's another land. And then we
battlefront. And then if I get good luck
this time, I might be able to actually
have a clock on this person instead of
just flailing around.
Um,
that's pretty good against the Basa.
That's good card advantage. I think
that's about it.
Basic like a basic uh banish effect
would be pretty bad against the basa
since it would re-trigger when it enters
again. But this replaces it with a
manifest. So that's not too bad.
Three mana thoughts for counter spells
is pretty bad, especially when it's the
best card in my deck. But, uh, if you're
playing against control, you got to do
what you got to do. Really? Okay. I I
did miss a land drop, so I think that's
that's not unreasonable. But actually,
no, that doesn't set me behind in lands.
Is that Is that the one that lets you do
it as well? Okay, that's a good card.
Um, grab an island.
Do I think they have another counter
spell? I'm
gonna hope the answer is no because I
don't have great plays other than
running it out again.
Yes, there we go. Okay, card draw. Yes.
Um,
the rest of these do anything? I don't
have a simul out.
Yeah, our bricks. That's fine.
I have no idea how to order things on
this deck in MGL.
We get rid of the creature removal.
I think it's fine to give up lanes
ultimately. Like the creature removal's
useless in this deck.
If I can just play out another United
Battlefront next turn, I should be like
kind of overwhelming this person with
value. I should play my secret coast.
Although, honestly, I think I'm going to
time out in this game. I was taking way
too long for this game.
Oh no. Why?
Okay. Well, I can flip my braided net
and draw a bunch of cards and that will
have to be good enough.
Yeah.
It's always so depressing to me when I
see somebody playing control
pretty badly, but uh I'm just unable to.
Okay, yeah, that's fair. Uh actually,
that's really really bad for me in this
case. I have I have zero backup plan
there. Wow. Okay.
Uh
I guess I can hope they're out of gas
and just slam a
Okay. The question is do I I guess I'll
see what I I'll see what I scri off of
this.
That might be worth saving for an
Elizabeth or something. That's kind of
kind of how they got ahead last game.
That's all pretty useless to me.
No, it doesn't even put a good clock on
them because I'm out of artifacts.
All right.
Okay. I'm glad I saved it at least.
All right. Okay.
Okay. We're getting somewhere.
Okay. Okay. Unless they have another
ultimate. They might. We'll see.
I probably lose this match overall even
if I win this game just because I'm
running out of time. But, you know, I
can at least put in some effort.
Another one. Wow. Okay. Yeah, we're
cooked.
Oh boy. That's bad. That's not good.
That's not good. I don't even have a
Yeah, I have no recovery.
Oh, that's bad.
It's bad news. That's bad news.
The fact that I lost the pre-board game
is not good at all. I should probably
board in a couple more uh counter spells
to my sideboard. At least one more.
Um,
I'm probably going to be ending the
stream pretty soon anyway because I need
to grab some lunch. Uh, but yeah, glad
glad you're able to tune in, Samwise.
See what I draw next turn. It's nothing.
I'll just scoop.
It's close enough to nothing. I don't
have artifacts to draw with that.
That was bad. That was brutal.
Oh, I blundered that first game so bad.
That was rough.
Oh, lord.
All right, I need to get something to
eat. So, I appreciate you all for for
tuning in. I'm sure I'll I'll name my
stream something that uh that uh makes
it sound more like a real stream rather
than a thrown together nonsense thing.
But yeah, it's fun. I will probably make
a habit out of streaming weekly. I was
thinking Wednesdays maybe might choose a
different day. We'll see. Uh I just
wanted to to to try out my streaming
setup and and try out some standard and
see how that went today. So no, that was
kind of fun. So
yeah, good stuff.
Yeah, it takes all of my attention to to
kind of,
you know, for for
30 or 40 minutes.
So it's it's important. I gotta Got to
save my strengths for that. Eating a
single lettuce leaf.
All righty. Thank you all for tuning in.